journalists the heroes that we root for
in movies like all the President's Men
the great Muppet Caper and most recently
spotlight we gotta nail these scumbags
we gotta show people that nobody could
get away with this
not a priest or a cardinal a freakin
Pope
I remember spotlight actually won Best
Picture at the Oscars this year meaning
newspapers finally received the
recognition that we normally reserved
the subject of such importance as the
incredible bravery of real-life
Hollywood filmmakers the incredible
bravery of fictional Hollywood
filmmakers and the incredible bravery of
wanting to your daughter's friends
but but one of one of the things that
made spotlights so powerful is the
knowledge that the newspaper industry
today is in big trouble
papers have been closing and downsizing
for years and that affects all of us
even if you only get your news from
Facebook Google Twitter or Arianna
Huffington's blockwork Junction and book
excerpt Clearinghouse those places are
often just repackaging the work of
newspapers and it is not just websites
watch how often TV news ends up citing
print sources according to the Chicago
Tribune according to the Detroit Free
Press according to the San Francisco
Chronicle according to The Times
Picayune the Boston Globe the Orlando
Sentinel the Philadelphia Inquirer the
Pittsburgh tribune-review the Detroit
News and the Houston Chronicle reports
the Los Angeles Times reports The
Oklahoman reports The Hartford Courant
reports the Salt Lake Tribune reports
it's pretty obvious without newspapers
around to cite TV news would just be
Wolf Blitzer endlessly batting a ball of
yarn around and it is not just news
outlets stupid shows like ours lean
heavily on local papers in fact whenever
this show is mistakenly called
journalism it is a slap in the face to
the actual journalists whose work we
rely on I'll give you just one example
two years ago we ran a piece on state
lotteries and a not insignificant
portion of it was built on the work of
Harry Astaire a reporter at The
Oregonian here is a clip we used of him
talking about this series on camera Here
I am quoting one of his Oregonian
stories directly and Here I am doing it
again you probably didn't notice it at
the time because you were too fixated on
my balls choice of shiny gray tie we
check a dress shirt the ty says mafia
funeral the shirt says high school
debate tournament and the face says I am
not confident enough to carry this lock
off but but the point is we used a lot
of hairy steps work in that piece and
and we try to add new information to our
stories our researchers work incredibly
hard but the media is a food chain which
would fall apart without local
newspapers and the problem is print ads
are less popular than with advertisers
than they used to be and online ads
produce much less revenue I'll show you
between 2004 and 2014
newspapers gained two billion dollars in
online ad revenue unfortunately in that
same period they lost thirty billion
dollars in print revenue so that's like
finding a Lucky Penny on the sidewalk on
the same day your bank account is
drained by a 16 year old Belgian hacker
and this has led to cutbacks in
newsrooms again look at the Oregonian it
used to be a big moneymaker in fact in
1993 their editor talked about how proud
he was of its record of success I've
been at that paper more than 40 years
and every year I've been there I've seen
our staff increase I've seen our
salaries increase not a years gone by
that an employee at the Reunion
full-time employee has not been a
beneficiary of a raise now that level of
confidence is almost tempting fate
he's like a citizen of Pompeii saying
what I love about this city is how
volcano-proof it is not a year goes by
without us not having to have our
horrified reactions captured in Ash
forever
unfortunately the Oregonian circulation
has since dropped and in 2013 just as
hairiest EV was working on his lottery
series their parent company advanced
publications dropped a bombshell this
picture tweeted out from inside the
Oregonian shows staffers listening as
editor Peter Bhatia broke the news some
had feared the paper will split in two
stop seven-day-a-week Home Delivery and
lay off some employees this is an a
strategic move to really focus everybody
on what that digital
future is and what our digital products
and services can be it's true they
became a digital first company and
digital first sounds like a high school
euphemism for seductively sucking on a
finger I put my finger in his mouth we
totally got to digital first it was like
ooh but it was also like hot and that
that meant big changes a local weekly
the willamette week got their hands on a
PowerPoint presentation for the
Oregonian staff outlining the fact
reporters would be expected to meet a
quota of three blog posts a day and on
any post of substance they would have to
post the first comment and what better
way to win the trust of your readers
than posting first underneath your own
article those rules were widely
criticized and have since been relaxed
but extra digital demands being placed
on journalists is now common throughout
the industry just listen to Washington
Post editor Marty Baron who you might
remember as the guy Liev Schreiber
played in spotlight he describes his
concerns about the average workload
required of journalists they have to do
their traditional reporting they have
participate in social media they have to
produce a wire service that's available
24 hours a day they have to be
responsible for video you name it
they're involved they're involved in it
it's a lot to ask that's true and if
journalists are constantly required to
write edit shoot videos and tweet
mistakes are going to get made perhaps
that is how the Boston Globe wound up
tweeting following a shooting in
Tennessee that the FBI had invested
farted about 70 leaks clearly if they
had more time they would have written
hashtag investor farted because that's
how you drive the conversation hashtag
investor party
now now add the Oregonian and the
Oregonian those digital demands came
just as almost a quarter of the newsroom
was laid off and over time even more
staffers left the paper including State
House reporters a two-time Pulitzer
winner and Harry is Steph so his work
bolstered our lottery piece and now the
lack of his work has bolstered this
journalism piece so you can't say that
we don't use every part of the hairiest
EV but here is where it gets frightening
because while the Oregonian rebuilt its
Statehouse team other papers have been
forced to simply go without a study of
over 200 papers found between 2003 and
2014 their number of full-time State
House reporters declined by 35 percent
and that's not good because while there
are some great web outlets
some of which do cover local government
there aren't nearly enough to replace
what has been lost just listen to David
Simon who before creating the TV show
the wire worked for years at the
Baltimore Sun the day I run into a
Huffington Post reporter at a Baltimore
Zoning Board hearing is the day that I
will be confident that we've actually
reached some sort of equilibrium you
know there there's no glory in that kind
of journalism but that is the bedrock of
what keeps you know got the next 10 or
15 years in this country are going to be
a halcyon error for state and local
political corruption is gonna be one of
the great times to be a corrupt
politician well you know I I really envy
them I really do he's right because not
having reporters at government meetings
is like a teacher leaving her room of
seventh graders to supervise themselves
best-case scenario Brittany gets gum in
her hair worst case scenario you no
longer have a school
I look it is clearly smart for
newspapers to expand online but the
danger in doing that is the temptation
to gravitate toward whatever gets the
most clicks
which is why news organizations badly
need to have leaders who appreciate that
what's popular isn't always what's most
important but that is not always the
case look at Sam Zell a billionaire
investor and living garden gnome nine
nine years ago he took over the Tribune
Company which owns newspapers like the
LA Times the Orlando Sentinel and the
Chicago Tribune after acquiring the
company he spoke to the Sentinels
nervous staff outlining his vision and
listened to one particular exchange with
a journalist his his last two words are
perhaps the most illuminating 11 very
simple I want to make enough money so I
can afford you it's really that simple
okay you need to in effect help me by
being a journalist that focuses and what
our readers want and therefore generates
more revenue but what readers want a
puppy dogs II mean we also need to
inform the community sorry I'm sorry ah
I can't hug him you're you're giving me
the classic what I would call
journalistic arrogance of deciding that
puppies don't come hopefully they get to
the point where our revenue is so
significant that we can do puppies
interact okay
whoa Sam Zell just created an inspiring
new motto for the Sentinels masthead all
the puppy news that's fit to print and
maybe some Iraq news too if we can
afford it
q now now the good news is Zell no
longer owns the tribune company the bad
news is their latest attempt to balance
business pressures with journalistic
responsibility has not been
confidence-inspiring just this year its
publishing arm tribute publishing was
rebranded into something much much
stupider this is the future of
journalists this is the future of
content it doesn't get much better than
that if you care about media and
technology this is the place to be
Truong stands for attribute online
content yes trunk they have chosen to
call themselves trunk which sounds like
the noise and ejaculating elephant mates
or or more appropriately the sound of a
stack of print newspapers being thrown
into a dumpster and if you are wondering
how trunks business model will be
different get ready to have your minds
trunked one of the key ways we're going
to harness the power of our journalism
is to have a optimization group this
trunk team will work with all the local
markets to harness the power of our
local journalism feed it into a funnel
and then optimize it so that we reach
the biggest global audience possible
what did she just say they're going to
feed journalism into a funnel oh we're
just going to take content and simply
cram it down your throat like you're an
abused goose and the corresponding
visuals make even less sense what is
happening here it looks like a bunch of
digital sperm impregnating a trunk egg
filming but what seems at first like a
banal corporate rebranding speech
quickly goes off the rails with their
next big idea artificial intelligence is
going to allow journalists to do their
jobs more efficiently
finding the right photos the videos the
databases the things that you were
packaged your stories with right now
that's a manual effort with artificial
intelligence you can create a system
that automatically is doing that for you
ok ok ok putting aside the news robots I
would like to take a moment to break
down what may be the most meaningless
graphic ever created we take a look on
the left there is the phrase
reading habits but once those reading
habits undergo X they become increased
consumption
it almost feels like a test and the
first employee to raise their hand and
say that doesn't mean anything becomes
king of the news and look it is easy to
make fun of tronc I could happily do it
for another 20 minutes but the truth is
publishers are desperate no one seems to
have a perfect plan to keep newspapers
afloat
one option seems to be to pray you get
bought by a billionaire benefactor who
could afford to swallow losses Amazon
founder Jeff Bezos bought The Washington
Post in 2013 and since then they've done
some spectacular journalism and the
reporters seem pretty happy despite some
of his stupider ideas like and this is
true a game that would allow a reader
who didn't enjoy an article to pay to
remove its vowels which is just absurd
taking out all the vowels makes every
word sound like the name of an app I'll
give you an example Turkey is a nation
in crisis Turk is a dating service that
helps you long-haul truckers but but
there are potential downsides to having
a rich owner especially if there is a
concern that they could meddle with the
papers coverage just look at what
happened to the Las Vegas review-journal
last year it was acquired by Sheldon
Adelson at the billionaire casino
magnate and Republican mega donor he's a
big deal in Vegas and his businesses are
at the center of a lot of stories the
reviewed journal covers but while
Adelson and the papers editors have
strongly denied that he interferes with
news coverage in any way the editors
have admitted that they put any articles
about him or his business through a
special review process to make sure that
they are fair although listen to an ex
deputy deputy editor describe his
experience of that process in this
review process things are changed things
are added things are removed there's no
explanation for why and there's no
appeal more than once reporters have
asked if they could have their name
taken off the story and have been told
no that's not allowed anymore there are
things that are done because it's known
that this is the way Sheldon Adelson
wants it to read and it can be something
very minor or it can be something very
very big
now if that's true that is very
compromising there could not be a worse
owner of a paper in Vegas than Sheldon
Adelson with the possible exception of
cirque de soleil because they wouldn't
even give you a newspaper you just have
a fistful of glitter
thrown in your face by a 90-pound man in
a thong and and look look none of this
is to say that there aren't people
producing great work in local news rooms
right now many are at the Oregonian at
the review-journal
even at trunk but they are doing
it despite their current conditions and
the truth is a big part of the blame for
this industry's dire straits is on us
and our unwillingness to pay for the
work journalists produce we've just
grown accustomed to getting unused for
free and the longer that we get
something for free the less willing we
are to pay for it and I'm talking to you
the person watching this segment on
YouTube using the Wi-Fi from the coffee
shop underneath your apartments killing
us
so later we are either going to have to
pay for journalism or we are all going
to pay for it because if we don't
not only will malfeasance run amok but
the journalism movies of the future are
going to look a lot more like this in a
city built on secrets I'm hearing
there's corruption in City Hall
only a newsroom willing to stop at
nothing can uncover the truth and might
go all the way to the top all the way to
the top a new and I think we could prove
that they knew
yeah I'm just not sure what can I clicks
we're gonna get on that you know anybody
else I've got a thing about a cat that
looks like a raccoon or it could be a
raccoon it looks like a cat wait I'm not
sure now we're talking yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's great let's figure that out
all right yeah maybe an online poll it's
political corruption in Boston we'll
come back to that if we have time but I
like the rat cat rat cat that's great
what blow the roof off that eats the
movie critics are hailing as genuinely
deflating and depressingly accurate The
Oregonian raves but who needs a Drake
for reporters uh actually I'm taking a
buyout three reporters technically I'm
not a reporter I'm the director of
social media strategies but I consider
myself an important part of the editor
to reporters I'm also leaving I'm being
replaced by Ripa though this is one
reporter and some kind of burnt orange X
choose the story of a lifetime what is
the thing dog until RocketBallz we're
talking all the way up to the mayor I
got kids man I want to sit - yo yo honey
is all hey nobody Holley and Arica
mcdonnen Hey sorry to interrupt
hi hi doing buddy I gotta talk to you
about your Twitter it's like a ghost
town in here what's going on man we
talked about this eight tweets a day I'm
in the middle of t-bone how many tweets
eight that's right okay we're not
counting retweets he wasn't just up
against the most powerful voices in City
Hall I need answers and you're the only
one who could give him to me he was up
against the most powerful voices at his
newspapers fair in
we gotta show people that no one can get
away with this we got a nail League
scumbags let me stop you right there
hopefully we can get to the point where
we can do racoon cats and City Hall but
we're not there so few the
journal-constitution raids actually we
had to get rid of our full-time movie
reviewer nine years ago so we haven't
seen it yet and the Las Vegas
review-journal says for fun and
excitement look no further than Sheldon
Adelson's casinos and resorts don't care
about you people I still believe in
newspapers I hear you but technically
you don't work for a newspaper anymore
you work at a multi-platform content
generation distribution network now the
REC cat is it adorable or skim you know
what it's like it's cute could it be
scary though we could make it scary as
mics get some clicks cuz some retweets
get some forward I'm talking about
corruption in City Hall yeah we're gonna
get back the archdiocese gotta keep it
moving I gotta keep it moving we just
need a story we can fun okay bud
you know yeah there you go like a little
piggies tail funnel vision exactly think
of like a witch's head upside down went
for the car monocle actually we
rebranded yeah you work for short
is charm hey there you go that's a good
idea for a story stoplight he tried to
break the story he was told to pump the
brakes
oh hey Tommy hey got great news for you
I'm gonna take you off that whole City
Hall thing have you worked the raccoon
cat beat with Chloe air cat record
Melissa
reckon cow anyway I really want you to
dig on this thing okay you know dig like
a raccoon cat stop light
coming soon to a midsize American city
newspaper near you